Let's put your newfound
knowledge to the test.
For this question I want you to make
some updates to the Hometown Project.
If you need the starter files,
check out the instructor notes for
instructions on downloading that.
Here we can see what it
looks like right now.
We've got two columns, text and
images, and we've got the weather and
sports scores.
When we resize the page,
it's pretty clear that the content
is no longer fitting the browser.
Let's go ahead and make it responsive.
First, add a meta view port to the page,
and
don't forget to set the initial scale.
Then I want you to make any
adjustments to the CSS in markup, so
that everything displays
in a single column.
Be sure to use relative widths, so
that things stretch to fit
across any viewport width.
And then finally,
check your touch targets and
make sure that they're big enough.
Once you've made your changes, test
your site across different viewports.
Try it on phones, tablet's,
and different desktops.
And when you're done,
here's what it should look like.
Notice, to start off with,
everything's in one column.
And when I resize the page, the content
reflows to fit the new viewport.
And of course, my buttons are nice and
big and easy to press.